Aquí nos piden encontrar 2 por "f" de 8,
más 8 por "g" de 8,
y aquí tenemos las gráficas de ambas funciones
esta es la función "g" de "x"
y ésta "f" de "x".
Así que pues vamos a encontrar
cuáles son los valores,
en estos puntos de "x",
en cada una de estas funciones.
Veamos "f" de 8.
Vamos a buscar en el eje de las "x",
nuestro valor 8, que es éste,
y nuestra función "f",
que es esta de aquí abajo, vemos,
que el valor,
cuando "x" es igual a 8,
es -6.
Este valor es -6.
Y "g" de 8 ¿cuánto es?
Bueno, tenemos este mismo valor
en "x"... 8
pero ahora lo vamos a buscar en la función "g",
vamos hacia la función "g" de "x" valuada en 8,
es este punto,
y nos lleva a 7 positivo,
este valor es 7,
bueno, ahora vamos a resolver todo esto.
Nos dicen que es 2...
por
-6...
esto es por,
-6
más,
8,
por "g" de 8, que encontramos es 7...
por 7.
Ok, 2 por -6 es -12
y 8 por 7 es 56
56...
56 menos 12 es...
56 menos 12,
Es 4,
4,
es 44,
esta respuesta es igual a 44.
Y con esto hemos terminado.